hello listeners i have a clothing line
and it's called sleepover by esther and
we have hand
dyed all hand sewn made in la
i designed everything and it's all it
all has special themes
and you can go to sleepoverbyester.com
to check it out i'm really excited for
you guys to see our new drop
hi guys i have been having a blast on
the road i'm so glad to be back there
please slugs come out and join me for
live stand updates i have uh one
headlining set
on july 15th at flappers in burbank
california
i am coming to wiseguys in salt lake
city
july 16th through 17th i
am going to the tempe improv 8
6 to eight eight
i don't hate it i wouldn't i could never
wear it
yes you could the way we saw your
titties in that pink one
the ruffle arms to me is drawing
attention to my eye my arms are like
excuse me disgusting there is there the
only person who can't wear a shirt like
that
is me oh my gosh oh my everyone so okay
by the way
everyone's full of [ __ ] the only person
that shouldn't be
that should be wearing this shirt is
jordan you guys the only reason bobby is
with me is for my wide broad manly
shoulders
i can't wear i can wear sleeveless shirt
it's just not ruffled because it does
look
like the shoulders much the vaginal kind
of i literally want the smallest [ __ ]
in the world
oh my god you guys i have the smallest
[ __ ] in the world
where you'd have a smaller vagina than
esther would be really i have a smaller
vagina than you i think
i have let's be real i have the biggest
one i'm jealous i want a big one
how are we measuring size because here's
here's what i'm jealous
of i like vaginas your whole body
it actually goes after your teeth oh
i've seen that i had a romanian friend
because we were all swimmers so we all
showered together right
seen that vagina i swear to god guys
came and [ __ ]
inch from her belly because the split
just was real high
yeah i was like oh my god what a plate
like was it just a sweater was it open
it wasn't opening wishes the slit came
up real high and her [ __ ] crack went
up real high she's lucky
she had like the joker would you guys do
something for me
as for my entertainment of course i
really want to see
kalila in your shirt okay oh my god
it's not gonna be good oh my god oh my
god
obviously oh my god i'm gonna i'm i'm
gonna sweat
in it my armpits disgusting look at her
body
oh she's so good oh my god it looks so
cute
you into like middle school but no i
know what you mean like
it's not you guys it actually looks so
cute you're i don't know what sort of
negative pandering you're doing no i the
thing is i just hate those
kinds of sleeves this is not a good look
guys that looks great
wait face me more she's showing us like
her triceps are a bad thing
i look at our triceps she's like look
how strong i look
like a masculine one
[Music]
thank you for doing that your dream has
not been realized yes sir you know what
i like you better
in your like down and dirty thank you
boyish stuff me too
i'm the same way by the way last night
kalylah
facetimed me for like two seconds and i
was in bed and dave was next to me
you know when you get off the phone and
then you just see you see your face
he's like so pretty and i was like
really me
and he's like oh no kalylah that was so
sad he was like oh no i'm still she's so
pretty i'm still taking it in
it was really sad you are pretty esther
in fact you know what this is when i
think you're prettiest right here
thank you this is the maester this is my
one girl what if she was saying
i like you the best like this like in
person because it doesn't translate
you do have like a very like rich
person's look today like i feel like
you've picked it up like
you're in a bright orange you have
froofy arms
look at those nails they scream private
uh
high school oh my god someone posted
someone came out to one of the show oh
the show i did with you
when we did john's oh yeah someone
posted a video i'm gonna start being
like you cannot take any
video at my shows some guy posted a
clip of me saying i was doing a whole
thing where i was like i kind of
understand like when you because i
performed at the mall of america and i
was like
you're around all these teenagers you
regress you start to feel like a
teenager all of a sudden you're hitting
on a teen
and the thought crosses your mind i
could [ __ ] a kid i said something like
that yeah
they they filmed just me saying i could
[ __ ] a kid
and posted it like with like little like
emojis and stuff and i was like
um if you take this down they're like oh
i didn't even listen i was just excited
to see you i didn't even listen to what
you were saying
like they just supposed to be like i
[ __ ] children i was like oh my god get
this down
that's real hollywood of you i know
you're in baby you're maturing
i don't [ __ ] them to like for pleasure i
[ __ ] them to get them excited so i can
get their adrenal
fans going no i don't know what you're
saying but
no it's hollywood the view that you
don't want something
circulating like that
you know it's hollywood you pretending
like you don't know about the adrenal
gland thing because
you are the most hollywood of all of us
you're the tv star
[Music]
i don't know you're a television and
film star
[Music]
i mean the stage
[Laughter]
i would love to see you in a [ __ ]
place i would
love to play i've always wanted to since
i've been here like write and produce a
play
let's do it let's oh i didn't say with
you but
can we be can we at least audition yes
yes
can i when i do my play i want to be the
only one in control
you said you would be the only one in it
hey by the way you're not going to write
it so i don't know what the [ __ ]
yes i am oh tips happen on the computer
esther's going to stay up an extra hour
every night and write her play
or one more play i'd like to audition to
be the lights guy
that's it the lighting designer
we need something with way more
experiences your shoulders will be
knocking in the way a little bit
wait i actually just had a flashback of
auditioning for a play because you guys
know
i've spoken about like the one thing
that can truly humiliate me
besides like my medical nudes getting
out singing singing
medical news yeah like i mean regular if
i take a nude that i send on purpose
like
i want it to be that's original medical
nude is like what i would send her where
i was like is what is this
like if those nudes if these nudes got
out like
i would die those would be bad my
ingrown pictures
to my friends i made up medical news so
it's not like a thing you should know
okay i'm trying i'm testing it out i
like it i'm now gonna look for all my
medical news and just trash
because i had a nightmare that that
happened i had a nightmare that i was i
all of my nudes leaked and it was
happening at such a rapid i couldn't
stop them like it was like
whack-a-mole like just so many nudes and
they
but they weren't good ones like if a
good nude i'm like
god be with us somebody leaked them
somebody leaked mine don't
don't don't actually just kidding i've
never taken a nude i don't want out
i have unfortunately only like one of
the thousand that i take is good and
sometimes i'm too lazy to delete the
nine hundred
delete there's a delete pile that
doesn't go away for like 30 days well
i'm [ __ ] so we've never taken nudes
no comment oh my god she is the
she has the most nudes out of three no
no definitely not the most
i feel like i have the least i just
don't take a lot of pictures of myself
the thing with esther is when she wears
like form-fitting clothes and stuff
she's not a child
you go like oh my god that actually
isn't a kid this is so weird
when she wears the baggy stuff i'm like
somebody needs to be chaperoning this
child
why is she alone in your eyes i'm just
going to go straight from child to old
lady like there will be i will get no in
between
no you're both right now that's how the
asian that's how the asians work you go
from
young young and then at 80 you go
completely gray
are we can we just be asian can we just
say we're asian i
appreciate the asian culture so much my
trip to japan
the food i could not live without the
food
i just had a revelation i think you
should be cast in a tokyo shock movie
what's that like old boy what do you
think about
tiny little esther tokyo shock movies
are like
old boy like boy are we talking about
that's just esther's
character there's this scene an old boy
where
he is at a sushi um restaurant and
he orders octopus and the octopus is
still alive
and the octopus while he's eating it the
tentacles sort of grab
his face and he continues to slurp it up
if you
were in that scene she'd be the octopus
oscar nominated speaking of octopus
i actually have a story i have not
shared on this podcast it's quick but
one time dave and i were in vegas and i
was like
being kind of we've been together maybe
like a year
and i was like trying to encourage him
to like take charge a little more so
it's like today we're gonna go to lunch
and you just order
and i'm just gonna be like your little
your little [ __ ] and i'm gonna eat
whatever you order
such a trap and i'm gonna like it's
gonna be really hot right he's gonna be
like this dominating boyfriend this
dominating partner
so we sit down he orders a bunch of food
and he's like okay
so here's this like thank you and then
he's
and this is octopus here we go and i was
like
no i can't he's like no because he was
like playing the role he's like no you
have to
i start crying hysterically he duct
tapes you to the chair
he whips you he's like no you're gonna
try it i just like start crying i'm like
please stop
please i can't eat it and then he was
like all right this is over
it like backfired and went in like the
worst way did he eat it
yeah he loved it he knew that was gonna
happen dude but he always brings it up
he's like oh yeah that went really well
like i just i completely collapsed when
i did you're very much like bobby
really bobby really faints a lot of
things that he isn't like especially
with food because he's like he's asian
right so when i started dating him i'm
like oh thank god he's an asian guy like
he's gonna eat everything with me
and he always says oh i can't date white
girls because they're just so picky with
food
he says that a lot but then we go out to
eat
and the way i like to eat it's like you
know it's all of it right
do you do you eat like eyeballs i'll eat
anything
you guys i went out to lunch with my
friends we wanted to get crab legs like
cooked crab lips of course and the place
was closed we were in koreatown yeah
so we went to this place called i think
it was called crab house and we walked
in
and it was like it's the most authentic
asian cuisine you could possibly get
where we ordered all this crab and stuff
we're like so excited everything was raw
yes i immediately was in like an episode
of the challenge where
it's the food episode i'm like it's all
mental it's
everything was cold and wet and slimy
so i don't want to say it you're not
even that's something you've never seen
or used
i've never it's never come into my life
to get raw crab did you eat it
of course i did and how was it i
actually liked it but my friends kept
gagging
and it really i was like we're being
rude and then the chat came in it was
and i was like okay you could puke on
the [ __ ] table at this point these
people
saw some whities come in and we're like
and we ordered like way i was like what
should we order and the lady just like
our entire table was just filled with
[ __ ] we did not want to eat so i was
rallying and trying to eat enough to
make it like worth the
price yeah but my friend was like dry
heaving she puked outside of a video of
her vomiting
did you like it at all i did if i was
with kalila or someone that liked it i
would have
eaten the entire thing yeah but they
it's not like they poisoned my idea of
it but it was
it was a new texture that i would have
had to have encouragement to get through
yeah that's the same way i feel about
have you guys had natto
have you had no what is that it's like a
fermented
bean that it's like in when you get it
or you're like this is not dough it's
kind of like
you know how durian some people love it
some people there's no in between i sort
of like it i sort of don't you either
like like natto or you don't like natto
because it's very slimy
and it's a little bit fermented it's
like that ew i think i have it looks
like cheesy beans
the first time i ever had natto i was so
sure that i would love it because i'm
like
what there's still such few things i
don't like yeah
and i ordered the biggest bowl of natto
and
that was the first time that like i was
so embarrassed
to not eat it because when the when i
ordered it the um the waiter was like
are you sure you've had natto before and
i lied and i was like yeah of course
like i've had japanese food my whole
life
and he was like are you sure i'm like
yeah i'm sure and then now i couldn't
um i had to double down okay so jules
was seeing me the tears coming out my
eyes and like bubbles coming out my nose
i ate the whole bowl of not though but
what was so bad about it
it was very late it was like it's not
it's like snot
what's the taste it tastes like beans um
fermented so it's like fermented snot
and um i i really tried
my best and some people really jules
liked it i'm like of course
stupid [ __ ] of course you like let's
get some of this for the show
fernando yeah yeah and i really want to
like it smell i don't want to
it doesn't have it it doesn't have a bad
smell
when you do ayahuasca again will you
take a picture of esther and i in your
pocket
uh you are in my heart i already talked
about think about us and have
revelations on our behalf
you really feel in your heart i already
had a hole when she was like um
it's so uncomfortable when i talked
about drugs i like please and the energy
after an ayahuasca trip is like
not okay for anyone else like it's so
intense and the people are like why are
you i know that's always when
when [ __ ] start youtube channels like
every time like i've seen a girl do
ayahuasca the next day she has a youtube
channel
like that of the master cleanse right
like talking about like
her revelations and like that it can't
relate to it
it's just so personal i was when i was
in austin there was this guy
he just looked like a kid that wanted to
talk about doing acid and he sure was
i was like everything about you is
exactly what you're doing
but so there was my the not my opener
i'm sorry i was open i was opening for
bonnie mcfarlane and then there was this
kid gabe i can't remember his last name
who
was the host he was a nice guy but he um
does not do hallucinogens right so i'm
sitting outside with these guys
and the acid kid comes up and he's like
just launching into stories about acid
and the kids going like i don't
i don't do hallucinogens right so that's
your cue to back away yeah
unless someone asks more questions but
so then he's like he starts he goes yeah
and then this one time i took three
uh tabs of acid and the kid gave the kid
gabe just goes i don't is that a lot or
a little i don't know
i love you leave it alone i love you
leave him
alone i'm like you have to stop is that
a lot or is it a little
that doesn't mean anything to me so then
later the kid was like no i had a good
sword again i'm like
it's not a good story i promise i've
done this to people i see people's eyes
glaze over
but you keep going girl well that's my
thing she eventually gets you back
though that's the persistence of annie
is that
there might be a momentary glaze but
then she just comes with something even
harder and more outrageous and you're
like wait wait wait
back up what did you say what did i miss
i also know how to draw you
in because it has to do with you but
what's your what's your
advice for someone like me and that guy
if someone's coming at us with like
drug stuff and we're like bro like i
don't care like what could we say to
bro i don't care yeah hey you're
enlightened you've done
you're so good at that esther just like
don't take this personally but i don't
care like why would i care this is
nothing to do i'm never gonna have this
experience
she's the best at that actually because
one time we were on facetime with a
friend of
ours and she was a friend of ours was
not an anti-vaxxer but definitely
you know giving her spiel about why she
wasn't gonna get vacant which fight
whatever to each his own
don't really care but that's exactly
what esther she was getting frustrated
just hearing it
from around the bend you hear hear her
say i don't [ __ ] care guys this
doesn't matter i'm so
bored because i'm bored just [ __ ] pile
everyone that started talking about
drugs just like treat them like you've
known them for years
well that's you know okay this is
actually a big topic like you know those
people
that just want to fight their side
yeah like we all have those people in
our life that loved one oh god
that will bring up the vaccine like
right now it's like the vaccine before
it was like
something about covid being like real or
you know
it's like at this point you do you
don't tell me about it there was this
like um
there was a keanu reeves quote that was
like i don't have time
to deal with crazy people anymore more
if you think two plus two equals five
like have at it yeah enjoy your life
that then ever since i saw i'm like
leave me out of this
this is how i feel like at the comedy
store because there's such a range of
people at levels of their careers and
stuff and
i talk to everyone so i'm like you know
friends with all the door guys and all
the
kitchen staff and then all of the big
guys too but
i always tell them like when they start
talking to me about open mics like if
you say open mic to me like
i'm out i go i have a strict policy that
i've passed
years ago i worked hard enough to not
have to go to open mics if you [ __ ]
bring an open mic up to me
you're dead to me i was like this is
your first warning
there's not another warning annie i'm
gonna start going to open mics and i'm
gonna
talk your ears
you're an exception and but i will
pretend like i don't like it to make you
go to open mics to do this
all right double down [ __ ] this is your
my natto
i used to host at the tribal cafe you
know that george you
used to what the aaa meeting
[Applause]
years after years not just a year that
was the one where you had to buy
they all have to buy yourself no one
wanted to hi-fi
do you remember me no you were uh you
were established by the time i was uh
thank you you were born established by
the way
she was [ __ ] established that's why
you had haters i was born with tap shoes
on my feet and a top hat on my head
what do you want to you guys want to
hear something so sad about tap dancing
why we were having such a long time
laughing we're having joy
why would we want something sad about
tap dancing i love
poverty poverty pavarotti
i'll hear about if you have a tap
dancing story about pavarotti i'm in
who's pomeranian oh my god pavarotti
esther
i feel like you should really know who
poverty i feel like you owe all people
you'd know pavarotti
he's one of your uh alternatives
is he like wait can you sing esther uh i
think anyone can sing if you get like
singing lessons there's just something
in me that's
just you might not be able to sing as
much as
like big singers but you can sing
something
fat singers no like christine aguilera
or she did gain weight after the boob
job oh my god don't talk about my
queen's like
i think she said it wasn't the boob job
it was when she went
on um what do you call it birth control
yeah but the one that you take depo
provera
i was on the depth you were one of them
was that the shot yes every yeah that
one okay that one
i got the shot you don't get your period
you're like oh this is so cool six
months
there's no free lunch [ __ ] that [ __ ]
came back
i had my period four six months after i
got off of it
non-stop for six months i gave a lot of
blow jobs i'll tell you that
why did we have to stop eating cereal
okay because cereal
had so many good feelings around it but
then it's like high in sugar
it's not good for you you feel guilty
q magic spoon comes in to save the day
zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving
and only 140 calories is serving it's
keto-friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free low-carb and gmo
free
dude you go do a set you come home you
eat your bowl of cereal
i'm literally jerry seinfeld and you can
build your own box
too you can choose between um cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
and cinnamon and what i like to do is
i mix the cocoa into peanut butter so i
can get my peanut butter cup filled
and for me it's all about fruity that
fruity flavor of magic spoon is one of
my favorite tastes on earth it's so good
i throw my almond milk in there i'm
happy
it's a happy meal for me you guys go to
magicspoon.com
bathgirls to grab a custom bundle of
cereal and try it today and be sure to
use our promo code bathgirls at checkout
to save five dollars off of your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt free cereal at magicspoon.com
bathgirls and use the code bathgirls to
save five dollars off and thank you to
magic spoon for sponsoring this episode
kleila you always dress so cute you guys
want to know my secret
what it's stitch fix look during the
pandemic i was just in sweatpants all
day
i was like how am i gonna re-enter
society like i don't know if i can
figure out what i want or what i should
be wearing
and thankfully for me i now have stitch
fix because
now i basically have my own stylist to
choose things for me
stitch fix offers clothing hand selected
by expert stylist
stylists for your unique size style and
budget it's completely different and fun
way to find clothes that you will love
to wear
every piece is chosen for your fit and
your life and it's the easy solution
to finding what makes you look and feel
your best annie i know you're with me
here
shopping is a nightmare do you feel so
insecure it's been the worst experience
it's not fun anymore
well you know they don't let you try
things on now too so you have to just
take it home
try it on so what's the point yeah
returns are the worst returns are
difficult
and you don't have to do that with
stitch fix in fact they send you a
return bag so if you don't want
something
you just place it in that like pre with
postage already in it and you just send
it out the door and there's no
subscription required which is awesome
so you can try stitch fix once or set up
automatic deliveries you'll pay a 20
styling fee for each box which gets
credited towards the pieces that you
keep and there's no hidden fees ever
and they have styles and clothing to fit
any occasion for women men and kids and
they ship all over the u.s and available
in the uk as well
get started today at stitchfix.com bath
girls and you'll get
25 off when you keep everything in your
fix
that's stitchfix.com bathgirls for 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
stitchfix.com
bathgirls
can we get back to my of sad yeah
filipino tap
are you sorry always okay
um so when i was younger i was four i
was just an athlete
my parents gave me no other avenue for
anything creative i couldn't take
painting classes i couldn't
that's really actually so mean it
nothing like i like to draw and they're
like shut up
do it do it burping yeah exactly i they
would rip the crayons off my hands and
be like do push-ups [ __ ]
it's annie's ideal child rearing that's
true out of someone's hand go ahead but
you know like they're like put blinders
on if you're going to be good at
something you're going to have a hundred
percent they're right yeah
they were right they were correct but so
there was this
tap dancing um group in our
international school
and i was just like i was just taken
i'm having a like a fun image in my head
of you
trying to sneak tap dancing but like
you're trying to sneak out to go tap
dancing but you're wearing the shoes
already so you're waking your parents up
with like the tap tap tap
the sad part is the shoes part okay do
you think
that my parents who wanted me to swim
would ever buy
tap dancing shoes so i remember looking
at bruce and diana just tapping away and
i would watch their performances like in
secret
um these were the popular kids that
popular tap dancers in their school
and so i asked my parents like can i tap
dance
and they were like you know shut up eat
your meal we're gonna go train right
so i got i saved cans of sardines
senorita sardines
and i flattened them these
the the cans and i um nailed them to
my shoes and after swim practice i would
be
in the back of the house and i'd put
music on and i would just like
tap for hours so this is like when you
want when you were a kid and you wanted
braces so you would take
the tinfoil i did that too yeah so i
tapped for hours so
i actually know how to tap but how did
you learn
to tap you just taught yourself copy
copied yeah
yeah copied i by the way
i could definitely like have i could
give you real tap lessons
please ask like i know my [ __ ] tap was
what i got my starting tap
i know my tap only fans only fans
did your oh my god the only fans is
i started rothie i swear
wait esther i'm just imagining your tiny
little tap shoes
oh my god do you ever hang them from the
no i get i
i usually get rid of my dance shoes
because my mom doesn't want to keep them
but
i because when i was little my mom took
me to it i said for some reason i said
like i want to tap dance i went to a tap
class and i was
they literally were like she's not good
enough she can't do it so then i had to
like go to like for baby tap
i was kind of a baby but how old were
you the
first dish gray like was it weird when
all the kids were taller than you
always my whole life but so then because
i had that first like she can't dance or
get out i was like the hunger was there
so i said he tapped basically from like
first grade through
senior year of high school so i know my
[ __ ]
this is the story of billy elliot by the
way
she's jilly elliot wait that's the play
that's the [ __ ]
right we have to be the mean people that
are like no that's a musical i can't
write them
i'm the villain with the with the tuna
can tap shoes right
that's not a villain i'm the parent
that's tearing the crayons out of your
[ __ ] hands
push-ups [ __ ] oh it's going to be a
broadway hit i can see it now
can i actually be cast as your mom and
not just in real life be your parent
ernie how the heck was austin how the
hulk was it how the hulk
how the holy because because austin is
like this new comedy scene and where
you came in from as an la person like
what was the hype was it real or how is
that
well i was told two things i was told
nobody in texas wears masks and that
there are not
homeless people and i will tell you i
was lied to
i saw a naked woman a fully naked
unhoused unclothed human walk across the
street
wearing not but to mask okay so not only
are there
people weren't the homeless we were
wearing masks she was completely i mean
i wish i had filmed it but i was like is
this revenge porn like i don't know i
can't film this naked woman
but she was she wasn't full she was
bottomless
and bush out shaved head not shaved
wow i love that look she was a little
overweight
yeah when you shave the top but just
keep the bottom bushy
that's such a trap yeah
also when i when you facetimed me from
there outside of your window
was a woman on a bicycle with a tutu but
no under undergarments
what yes she was she was right she was
everyone's
crazy she was a pedicab driver but
dressed as like a fairy
bottomless like vagina vagina yeah
and then definitely on meth like having
meth like
which by the way if you're going to be a
pedicab driver i think that's the job to
do math but her tutu was so high that it
didn't cover any of her bottoms so it
was
like are you serious right here right
before isn't that illegal
the whole thing's i mean i don't know if
there are police anymore i'm pretty sure
police are like you defunded us you
burned our cop cars please
but i yeah it was wild and i just i will
say this about
austin if you have a set of balls
i would run from that place why my ball
sack was sticking to my inner thigh and
i don't have one it was
it's so humid it's so sticky and i'm
assuming this is actually a good time of
year
so the sweat it just i can't even
imagine i'm into that
fully dilated makes me so pretty
i don't have eczema my skin is beautiful
oh my hair is fuller
and humidity i know a lot of people are
afraid of humidity but
i my skin is but my i don't i know it's
it's she makes
it sounds miserable like i don't want it
but my skin is
so much better in humidity i think
everyone says because you're fully
dilated okay let's move to the [ __ ]
house
not austin though we can do hawaii we
can do somewhere there's so many other
uh dilated i'm just imagining like
crowning you can't say dilated to me
yeah i'm thinking like yeah ready just
okay let me try and find another word
just
well oiled your your your insides
everything is flowing well
your heart's operating better better
your skin's not flaking off because this
is california is a chaperone i'm flaky
here you're flaky
dude my face snows
if you if i scratch my eyebrows it
starts snowing yeah
eyebrows dandruff like my skin is so
flaky but then when i go back to chicago
i'm like oily and like just like dewey
do we do have um dandruff hell yeah
i do too can i suggest why maybe you
have dandruff
because you use [ __ ] dish soap on
your hair no that helps
the dish soap has helped did you google
this or look this up is this like on the
back of goop magazine or something is
this like a secret
no i have extremely oil that's the thing
my hair is oily
i don't know so this is something this
is a fun thing
my hair is oily which i know doesn't
make sense because my skin is dry
but my hair gets really oily so i have
to sometimes use dish soap to like
you know those commercials with the
little duckies when they're like in oil
yeah and they use the dawn soap
you're oily because your skin is dry you
know that right
yeah people who who your body is trying
to
compensate for the dryness and that's
the same thing with me so it's like
that's why when you
overly moisturize the less oily you
actually become because your skin
doesn't
your body's not trying to um oil up the
flakes
itself it's so funny how dumb we are and
how smart she is well she's a [ __ ]
nurse
oh my god nothing to do with that
i'm just not reading goop magazine i'm
not reading there's no such thing as
google's
magazine oh there isn't i just think
that's just a website
it's a newspaper i have the same thing
esther because i have um
seborrheic dermatitis so
the dandruff doesn't end in the hair the
dandruff close to my cheeks yeah
then to the behind my ear and it doesn't
look like that
if it looks like red flaky patches and
it onto my chest
hell yeah itchy as [ __ ] i have nipple
hair dandruff
i have i don't i just have no place so
would you move to austin how is the
comedy scene
can you why am i like will you move to
austin the comedy scene is cool
it's really fun they have a couple clubs
right now joe's opening up a club and if
it's in the location that he said it's
gonna be so [ __ ] cool
but i know they're still looking around
but um
there's a place called the creek in the
cave that that's where bonnie performed
when
bonnie and i performed bonnie by the way
bonnie mcfarlane is like the funniest
[ __ ] on earth
i also think she's just the prettiest
she's gorgeous she's really so smart
she's so funny i love her i'm
always just like i can't believe you're
friends with me i just she's just
so good i was just like crying watching
her but
so guys go see her if you can do you
feel like you would ever go there
like oh i'm gonna go to austin for two
weeks and like get a bunch of stage time
like you would like like previously how
maybe you someone would do that in new
york would you ever do that in austin
now
i could see that as a good thing like
when i first started comedy in new york
i would come to la like twice a year
and do like a week of shows and you can
kind of clean up
in austin it is a smaller scene but they
they have the creek in the cave and they
have this place called the vulcan
that's really cool um and i went up
there but the problem with the vulcan is
it's like a
edm club so it's like it's got like the
stage
people around you then it goes all the
way up like two or three stories
then there's another st like another
floor around you with couches like a
nightclub
so when you're performing the sound all
goes up like i was 100 sure i bombed
like i was like i can't believe i'm
[ __ ]
bombing i was like sweating i was like
what do you guys want
and i got off stage my boyfriend all my
friend everyone was like oh my god you
just killed and i'm like are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] with me and they're like no dude
and all these girls i was getting all
these dm's people like
you were i'm like are you [ __ ] sick
because i was and i'm telling you that's
another reason why i don't want to live
in austin
when i physically sweat on stage more
than just my armpits
i because it's a symptom of bombing i
bomb
in my head wait where do you sweat other
than your armpits like your vagini or
your
your ch thank you for calling it a genie
it's granted many wishes for fat men um
many many fat men you just rub it and
okay but where do you i want to know
where you sweat and the butt crack
well yes it was swamp well because i can
only fit in sweatpants at this point and
i refuse to buy
i'm not buying a new size it's like i'm
a size four until the seams pop [ __ ]
like i do not care
but i'm like so i'm like high-waisting
these [ __ ]
grandpa sweats hell yeah i love that i
am
sweating nobody you know everyone's
wearing sweatpants in l.a
yeah nobody's wearing sweatpants and
awesome that's funny not even a question
are they all in jeans
they're all in like jeans and shorts and
like they know what they're doing
they're like we need air flow
i was swamp-assing but it was it was
like from my the part
of my head from my zenith down like i
was
[ __ ] sweating do you do you ever
sweat because i only get it
right here in my voice underneath my um
eyebrows
kurt broner calls it the moist moist
dash
oh it's so that's the most embarrassing
one is this the face sweat but only in
select areas how about when your fake
eyelashes catch the drips like they're
like it's raindrops coming from i mean i
just was like
you should get the salt in your eyes i
mean i really was just
sweating crazy my hair extensions just
felt so
heavy i was like what the [ __ ] do you
ever feel good that you sweat like
you're
that's like good for you well i don't
want to brag but i did
go to 8am hot yoga today you did
i did guys wow i did that's why being 10
minutes late was very
i was trying to like forgive myself for
that but a series of events happened
unfolded and i was 10 minutes late good
for you but i got up so early i was like
i'm gonna be
early speaking of edm and the vulcan
were you guys did you ever go through an
edm phase no
ever okay well i went through
i went through an 80 m m's phase oh i
did yeah but you guys never
listen like i went to the swedish house
mafia like farewell tour
i can never tell these things to bobby
so i'm never this is a secret between us
and this podcast but like i had a really
like i was really
into i like everything so when edm
was a thing it also was a thing in my
heart why did you like it
just good old party days you know what
does it mean to you like just it's a tim
it's like electronic
dancing it means ibiza ibiza
being like you know just a ratchet [ __ ]
in europe and can i tell you why i don't
like it because i'm so self-conscious
with my dancing and my singing
i can't like let loose the way you have
to when you're at an edm concert you
can't be self-conscious at medium
it's not like broadway would let
they don't dance but that's the thing
about
it it's true you're not you're not wrong
you do have to
there's a very like procedure with a
band that you could be very obviously
not awesome but it's the best
is the best type of music to not dance
to because
it's you're actually just in the crowd
and then i don't know what do you think
people are dancing i like the people you
know they're doing their little liquid
yeah but you have more pressure if
you're dancing to rnb
like because then you really have to edm
is just boom boom are you just jumping
yeah something's hard you could do that
although yeah jumping sucks i'm so
embarrassed about my
mind why are you embarrassed i like you
you should be embarrassed about your
bummer story about tap dancing
my sardine can
whether you're listening to this show
this show or lady gaga obviously
a pair of raycon wireless earbuds in
your ears can make all of the difference
it's true you get crisp powerful beats
at half the price of other premium audio
brands
and you know what i love about my recons
is that it actually comes with
a whole lot of different earbud sizes
because i'm really particular about that
nothing fits me but they give you like
six different ones it's weird it's so
much better than the other
options out there that actually cost
more raikon is better and they don't
hurt my years they don't really comfy
look great and feel even better they
come in a range of cool colors and with
customizable gel tips included for a
comfortable in-ear fit
the best part about the 24-hour uh
battery life is that i can take it on
the plane
you know how like you'll go on a flight
and then
the entire experience your your
headphones are dead by the time you get
your uber
you can go from start to finish of your
day listening to
this podcast or whatever you listen to
and it does not run out of battery this
podcast if you're unwell
you guys listen up raycon is offering 15
off
all of their products for our listeners
and here's what you got to do to get it
go to buy raycon.com bloodbath
and there you'll get fifteen percent off
your entire raycon
order and it's such a good deal you'll
wanna grab a pair and a spare
that's fifteen percent off of buy
raycon.com
bloodbath by raycon.com bloodbath
this next sponsor is really important to
our show because if you listen to this
show
you're not well you need help you need
better help
i need it this [ __ ] needs it and this
i'm on it i've
been on better health hell yeah better
help is professional therapy online
you just download the app pick a
counselor
unload your burden yeah i mean there's a
lot of things that interfere with my
happiness
including my anxiety you know my
long long long standing generational
trauma
things like that and those are the
things that um these counselors can
really help you with whether
it's lgbtq matters anxiety stress
relationships sleeping self-esteem grief
these licensed professional counselors
are specialized in
these particular things and you can send
a message to your counselor anytime
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
all without ever having to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
and i think you can you can get match
with a counselor in under 48 hours
correct
um this service is available for clients
worldwide too
we want you to start living a happier
life today and as a listener you'll get
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor betterhelp.com
bloodbath join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com bloodbath
so annie so esther your your um what do
you call it um
when someone can sing dance and act a
triple threat you're a triple threat
right you're a triple threat my parents
wouldn't agree but i'll take it
i think you're a triple threat i think
you can do it all what do they say
i can't sing i caught them on a hot mic
my mom basically sang like i feel bad
for her she's not going to get a part
oh i've walked into my parents twice
saying why was your mom on
like because i a long time ago i made i
was making this like
was it her play she wasn't casting you
in no no
i shot a pilot for hbo
like seven-ish years ago
where i went back to my this is like a
horrible story
this is what i want to hear it must have
been when we weren't friends a very big
production company was
like a very big producer was like i want
to do this harley weinstein
no is he my neighbor no okay
no it's a very big female producer and
so she's like i want to do this so she's
so basically like hbo and funnier die
like sent me
i went to my hometown i went to my
parents house my high school
theater program was having like a
50th anniversary where they were
allowing alumni to audition
so i went with cameras and like this
like
big producer came was like at my parents
house with me
and we were like filming and so i i was
prepping for my audition
and that's when we caught my mom on a
hot mic saying like i just feel bad for
her she's not going to get anything
i auditioned i auditioned for the music
hall
cameras are there my teacher knows
i don't get a role at all i get like
the offer to be in the chorus
i was so embarrassed and then like i we
we
sent in like the footage and like the
producer called and was like well
you don't really have a role so we don't
there's not really a show here
like how dumb is the person casting that
they weren't like
hbo will follow this entire maybe they
were trying to be funny
it was so sad this is like so
traumatizing i think it was a flex for
my high school and i also think that
they didn't want
to do it how terrible were you a high
schooler
that they the whole school is against
you were you coming in cocky passed away
fame
were you coming in talking like hey guys
alum here no i was not cocky at all i
was like
i was also so nervous and i kind of
blamed my parents because they like
had you they were like so
involved in the process when i really
needed like my own time to prepare
no i kind of became a big joke and i
didn't really take it seriously because
i figured like whatever
ultimately i think it wouldn't have
worked out because they said that the
school wouldn't sign off on the students
appearing on camera
now i think there was there had to have
been a way to work around that but i
think
that it maybe was never going to happen
so that killed the project yeah oh my
god oh my god that's
so funny and then there and then i tried
to get it going in another way because
then i wanted to do it where i just went
to a random high school and was like can
i be in this oh my god if this ended up
just being a series of you getting
rejected
i think that it can be a thing now i
would love that
i would not want to watch that they
should have just [ __ ] cast you should
win every role
so you look younger than these high
schoolers oh we can't put any high
schoolers on stage okay i'll play
every single roll i know they put tig in
army of the damn they can put you as
every character which by the way she's
getting such good reviews
it's insane what they did so what they
did is they blurred everything
in the background and zack snyder said
he did it on purpose what do you mean
ahead of time like for the look of it
they completely defocus the background
you know when you take like a portrait
picture
on your phone so everything in the
background is completely unfocused
and be and it makes it easier to put
taken so they completely took chris out
of the um of the movie and then they put
her
in it so she's like green screened every
single scene every scene like she hasn't
met some of the stars of the movie
oh that must have been really hard for
her i mean i mean imagine you're like
we're gonna give you an action starring
role we don't have much time there's all
this controversy around it and
go and also it was originally written
with the idea of
a man playing that role also the fact
that she had to even like
kind of like you know what i mean she
had to do that gymnastics of
but it is like one of these things where
it's like i do feel like i feel bad for
dalia because i think he would have
crushed it like i think he probably
really well he's a good actor i really
think like
and i think it would have just because
it was like the comedic relief role you
could just see
like i really i think it's wish i could
have seen i think it's obviously a weird
situation but i do think it's cool that
take
got the opportunity since like she
probably wouldn't have otherwise
and the fact that she's getting such a
positive reaction
people are loving it like and all the
pictures she looks really cool
i'm i'm down yeah no i mean i think it's
it's also like funny to give her
a woman i mean it's like that's like
you got punished kevin spacey when he
got replaced by like a 90 year old
christopher
plummer you know oh yeah remember that
and christopher plummer killed it i want
to
tell you my auditioning story it's worse
than yours
you're offering chorus so i went in for
my middle school was doing little orphan
annie this was like the one hiccup in
time where i was in public school for
like
a year and a half headaches had to take
a half a year off
but from school well they made me wear
sunglasses in school so i was either the
kid wearing sunglasses
in school or i was getting homeschooled
oh you were the you were the cool kid
wait you were homeschooled for six
months couple months yeah and then also
in um i feel like that in high school i
got homeschooled too for a little bit
because i my
ex-boyfriend was dating becky my
ex-boyfriend was secretly dating and the
school was so small that it was like uh
oh it was crazy so i ended up getting
homeschooled for mental health me too oh
my god
for mental health because i was put on
so many um 50 150 holds
i like i like call them 51.50 because
they were struggling to bring holds
we're understanding these tattoos oh
yeah i was a big cutter
um never the cutter yeah look at that
blackness
right here um no but my last couple
months in high school was in one
classroom
with my history teacher who took all of
my work from all of my other teachers
and piled them on my table so he could
keep an eye on me
and my uh my history teacher
picked me up from from um my house
and my um english teacher dropped me off
drove me home they wouldn't even because
i was taking the bus at that time
that i would like they were like look
this girl is smart
she's clearly having a really hard time
with her mental health
we need to just propel her forward
because i used to be a straight a
student we're like we just she just
needs a little bit of help right now so
these teachers rallied behind me
they didn't want me taking the bus
because god knows i would have ended up
somewhere
[ __ ] you know trying to kill myself
oh my god and they just kept a really
close eye on me and granted i graduated
with like straight d's but
but i cannot believe how
much they cared about i've never ideas
um did you ever cheat on tests by
carving um
the answers into your arms with a razor
blade oh my cheating tactics
well dude i cheated in a way where it's
like why didn't i just study
right now it was i okay i had a [ __ ]
teacher who i set this up for like six
months i always did the long con
yeah i said uh i was like oh it's really
easy i'm very tactile learner so it's
easier if i sculpt
during class like i so i would bring a
piece of clay into like science class
i would like i just i was like oh these
learning i have these alternative ways
of learning
so then i started like a couple weeks
before this exam i was like yeah
like i've been really like listening to
meditation music
are you secretly a con man i feel like
you always accuse me of being a con man
i told the teacher that um i needed to
listen to this cassette tape
that i've been studying with so he said
okay he okayed it ahead of time
so i recorded on my little cassette my
little boom box i recorded all the
answers
onto one half of the cassette and then
the other half was like bird sounds you
know
and then so i played it for him in the
beginning of class i go i'm not cheating
like here it is
and then i flipped it and but i [ __ ]
up i didn't put
time in between the answers so i
couldn't write as fast as i was talking
so i kept pausing and like i was like oh
my god i have to run
so i'm going to the bathroom like i just
had to be like i have diarrhea like i
was in the bathroom a million times
and it was so much harder than just
studying yeah it is so much harder the
only person you cheated is yourself
that's true can they revoke
um a degree or a diploma probably
to say that you've cheated i'm just not
gonna specify where
i cheated pharmacology was a very hard
thing for a lot of students but it came
easy to me
and um i'm just gonna leave it at that
but the best way to do it
in high school when you didn't have when
you couldn't program into your um
in your calculator obviously some of the
answers for like calc and stuff like
that
um you bring a water bottle but you take
out the
plastic in the water bottle and you
write all of the answers behind the
water bottle
so when you look at your bottle the
answers are all behind it
oh my god they're like magnified yes
and you can get caught with that one
really hard i don't know
not in high school because then they
weren't really looking for
ingenious ways i like to call it you
know to cheat like one time i had a
whole cast in my arm or my right arm
and i just put little paper scrolls
through it and if i needed an answer i
just would
pop it out pop it out i did my brother
and i my twin and i were taking driver's
ed
in philly we had to take like a whole
class
we took my parents had like one of those
old-school xerox machines where you
could keep xeroxing it at a lower
and just make things smaller and smaller
we took the like pamphlet of all the
questions
for the test and we shrunk it down to
like
this size like it was multiple choice
like did all the right answers
on it stapled it and just handed them
out to everyone so we are probably like
responsible for some vehicular
manslaughter and the northeast
water in the late 90s earlier you never
cheated esther ever
not really like i don't have any vivid
memories of it i
like my i was always when it came to
test taking
i was always the first person to turn
the test in and
like for better or worse like i just i
was very adamant
and dave like always gets on me about
this like in my adult life but i was
like i know what i know and i know what
i don't know so i
rushed through every test because i was
i'm never the type that's going to sit
there and be like
hmm do i remember this i'm like no i
know it or i don't
so i would just like speed through my
test always be the first person to hand
it in
and then sometimes i would even like
stand there and be like grade it right
now in front of me
oh my god i'd be like when she was born
i'd like wait what was this one what was
this one like i was
yeah wow you wouldn't even try for the
things
you didn't know would you ever direct
something i would yeah i would love to
direct
i feel like that's true i feel like
that's truly who i am you could
quadruple threat i think you have to be
really good at one of those things to be
a threat
and i don't think anyone views me don't
even say that esther you're my little
mini mogul
thank you we're gonna manifest it
because that's truly who you are you're
my mini
you're my mini mole the animal should we
banana break yeah
[Music]
while we banana break let me finish this
[ __ ] story
about how i went to audition for a
little orphan annie yes
and i just got russell thank you to a
place
yes where i thought i was going to be
able to pull it off
like i didn't think the nerves were
going to come in how old were you i was
11 or 12. i go in and they're like why
do you think you should be cast as annie
and i said because i'm annie
like thinking that would work and then i
just bombed it was the
the heat coming to the top of my head
boiling over humiliation i feel every
time i sing
i don't know if they try to get us a
dance guess what i got what part i got
what usher
my twin brother and i were ushers
oh my god wait they're getting him
allowed to be in the [ __ ] chorus
not even urger
not to brag but in my high school
theater you had to do crew in order to
qualify to audition
so i knew all the jobs who did your work
for you i
we i i feel like it's actually i take
this as a compliment because you think
i'm you
when you say that what crew job were you
doing built like we we had to do
everything you could not get away you
had to do
you had to work like you had to paint
like someone told you what to do
like i wouldn't know how to build a set
but it's like okay today you're gonna
like
paint this backdrop paint you know did
they did they make you build the ladder
you needed to
be able to paint the stuff i have this
project that
i'm doing and everyone's like kalyla
you talk for a living this should be
easy peasy for you
and you guys when we practiced this
thing i crumbled
like of all the people in the room that
don't talk for a living i'm the one i'm
the only one that crumbled
sweat mustache everything i'm like what
happens like what is it about
it's a fear of being judged by people
that you either are viewing as like
powerful
or like it's like not having control of
your life in that moment
right like you're giving your power to
these other people that's why you have
to like really just
be that's why whenever i do something
that's high stress i give myself
the honesty of it and i always say it
like if i'm like oh i'm [ __ ] nervous
right now like i'll always be like
just say it to kind of get it out there
and i think people like that i don't
know well that's what i do
you guys i'm so nervous i've never done
this before and then the filipino accent
just comes out so strong because i'm
trying not to have a filipino accent no
have the accent
then it's like good morning guys you
know
happy to be here i'm like oh my god and
then it i just spiraled because i'm like
oh they know it they picked up the
accent i have an idea
what get some sardine cans okay
if you tap dance in you'll be able to do
it from a distance on zoom just
yeah i haven't i have advice for you in
you saying you're really nervous about
whatever you're doing it may not help
like today or tomorrow but
everything is better with practice yeah
so it's like you're not gonna be good at
something the first time you do it and
you should just like
be okay with that and know that like
you'll have to probably do it
five ten times and then you'll be good
so whenever i'm not good at something
now i'm just like
it's just a practice thing it's not me
it doesn't reflect poorly on me i'm not
bad at this i just haven't done it
enough so podcasting
how we we need to hit our ten thousand
hours before i finally hit my pr
my stride no but really like it is it is
that thing and
because if you take the feelings you're
having personally then it's you're
[ __ ]
yeah i also have um i don't know if this
is an appropriate thing to say out loud
but i i have
the gays of powerful older not young
older white men really does something to
my
psyche um i don't know if it was because
of my father being like a very like
commanding force
and he was like a very like he was a you
know scary white person
i went to psycho i went to undergrad
psychology for eight years
yeah okay my mom wrote all my papers but
i can say yes that is what it is not
george kimmel
like he's my age whatever we're fine but
if it's like an exact type
i i'm so i feel so disconnected to their
world that i don't know how to tell them
who i am what if you could instead
place the good parts you thought about
your dad and just assume that they love
you like a daughter
would that work it could what i do what
i do
now is i i i look at each person and i'm
like oh
um you know i just look at him like it's
just a job it's just a job they're doing
they don't want to [ __ ] be here i
don't want to [ __ ] be here we just
gotta get through when they do a pitch
on zoom we'll make it so you only see
yourself
oh so you don't even look at those
people i don't know this insecure [ __ ]
it's gorgeous so gorgeous
look at my shoulders our supermodel
friend
who complains george do you have any
surprises for us
all right new segment alert
i do look like a hot cholo we should i
know i'm about now
i'm about to hit you want me to hit it
yeah you look like a guy in santa fe
i would [ __ ] sanify dude i would [ __ ]
this [ __ ] look at you
and you look like i can't tell that you
have tits too so it looks like a ripped
body
and you would definitely have like chest
tattoos and i would have peeners like
the little
cuts right here if i had a neck tattoo
right now
i think all you [ __ ] would ride my
face i would be
we would have to move that camera
because i would have slid right off this
chair
well our father we're going to confess
to you
this is called the confession booth
where nasty naughty annie and esther
confess our sins to father koloko
and i'm here to dole out your pen and
space yeah
we're going to start with um bless me
father for i have sinned okay
my turn yes okay bless me father for i
have sinned may the lord
help you to confess your sins dear
esther okay
so this is this is a confession
really to the people present here so
recently i've had a lot of out-of-town
dates that have made it really difficult
for george to schedule the show
and i said that i was going to be gone
june 8th
and i was a little shady about when i
would come back
i said the 20th but then
i no i said i was shady about when i was
coming back
kind of like left it up in the air and
then i heard that annie was going to be
out of town
and then i was like oh well i can stay
in skokie for extra days now
and so i may or may not have extended my
trip but said i was coming back on the
20th
but i'm gonna stay home longer because
andy's not gonna be here
do you guys remember just moments ago
when esther said
i really need this podcast to make money
that is not bad what i did because you
won't be here anyway chill
father will just try these children um
let me see let me scroll down
go hard father
[Laughter]
the archbishop has her hail mary is hail
mary to another podcast he'll marry your
ass to another podcast [ __ ] i can't
believe i really played the game and
gave a real confession and everyone's
mad at me
you like it though you're thriving right
how happy you look
esther do you thrive off negative
reinforcement yes
wow i'm now learning this i almost feel
like i shouldn't give you a penance and
tell you it's really not a big deal so
that you don't get the
the feeling of victory i know it's time
to take the [ __ ]
because i she's gone not gonna be here
anyway
listen [ __ ] for your penance you're no
longer my child
you're not my [ __ ] for your penance the
biggest spank paddle
is what i'm gonna go with the littlest
well actually it's a pretty big ass
pick a part of your body oh look there's
air going wow this looks like a
smack the filipino game sunka where you
put the little marbles
like um uh white castle burgers
wait why because white castle burgers
have holes in them they do
oh my god you never have it choose a
body part booty
okay let's go oh my god don't go too
hard because i'm
little oh my god she's so cute she want
to get spanx
she's a bad girl she's bad
i can't believe only fans is getting
this or pre-only fans wait give me the
other cheek too you can't just give your
right cheek
also you're gonna hit the mic don't ruin
our what if i poop
if you fart and fall forward i will die
laughing
one two three four five six seven
eight nine swipe oh my god she touched a
[ __ ]
i felt it i got a little wet father got
a little happy there
i had to go to the bathroom oh my god
did you pee pee white stuff
did you pick me white stickies don't say
that did you snail it out
it tickles that is actually more
punishing is tickle than pain
yeah i think so yes tickling is
the worst have you guys seen the tickle
documentary yeah
what esther please watch it it's worse
it's a darker
it's worse than being molested annie
don't say that listen
as most guys i don't know if you've
heard in a couple episodes
last night i did a show and nick thune
was on the lineup and i cannot remember
what the thing was
that we were talking about but he goes
well good thing you weren't molested and
i went wrong girl i went
nick wrong girl i thought we were
friends
i was like uh and then he was like
someone did not say that i swear to god
and i was like uh
like what do i do because if i don't say
i'm like a liar because he'll just
the minute he hears my name again it's
going to be attached to being molested
someone did not say that
so that i had to be like i was like oh
and he goes i go oh i got teacher
like bang or whatever and he goes oh at
least you were older i was like well
there was a thing when i was little too
but anyway
just have a good set and
annie my child yeah what is this big
confession
okay uh dear father i have sinned
forgive me father forgive me father
foreign
okay i already see your sins they're
they're too they're looking at me
that's your punishment you gotta watch
me tweak my nips
oh my god the pixelating is gonna be
crazy the pixelating budget
well that we'll use it for all the times
we can't record because you're out of
town oh my god
we all have out of town dates except for
kalyala mostly but you're bad too
oh i'll have out of town schedule-wise
are
the nightmare of the world there's a few
reasons why
your personality your temperament your
attachments i have to go see my grandma
the one who hates you i like you she got
a new house so i want to see it
we knew there was a twist do you think
you're going to get it or you're like oh
no i'll put my
bed here no where are you in the running
for
for um inheriting the house literally
don't you know the story i asked her for
a
dirty old vintage sweatshirt in her that
i found in her closet
and she said she had to think about it
and then two months later she gave it to
my sister
oh god i'm getting nothing uh forgive me
father for i have sinned
may the lord help you help forgive your
sins my dear child
years years years years years ago i was
house-sitting for a friend and i
found her vibrator
[Music]
i cleaned it off i put it in a sock
and i used it i then cleaned it again
put it back in the drawer
during or before crabs
it was well after the crab how old my
child could parasites have
25 jumped onto
this sad vibrator no but the funny part
is i did find out
very soon after that she has herpes and
i was like would that not be the
greatest way to get herpes ever
like the most deserving way to get
herpes are you like
already her vibrator but
wait is that is that a crime though like
i'm trying to see because you know we're
all about consent and all these things
like
sharing sex toys like what is there what
are the
rules i would not if someone used
something of mine that would be
really gross would you share well yeah i
would never touch one of yours
do you share toothbrush with no like in
an emergency
no not in an emergency here cholo god is
ready to give you your penance
oh my god please give me my penance you
ha honestly i'm so attracted to you
right now you look like
manny from good girls you look like
manny from
modern family but uh it's a bag of
shirts
with him no he's so cute if you go to
texas everyone looks like him by the way
okay so
let me see you almost gave yourself
herpes dear child
um i'm gonna go ahead and say that god
has already
um punished you enough with your teacher
and all of these things so i'm gonna i'm
gonna
i'm gonna have you choose your
punishment today do you get to live out
your karma after it happens to you
yeah yeah karma i got molested by my
teacher and now from now on i'm [ __ ]
putting my [ __ ] juice on everyone's
[ __ ] vibrator in my life
no you don't because because you'd be
perpetuating the hurt hurt you know her
people hurt people
i know i don't want to hurt anyone
deciding i would never do it again i
would never do it again
annie annie dear child
how would you want how would you like me
to punish you today
spanker and the [ __ ] spank my [ __ ]
you want to be spanked hold on give me
the other one
ass like no my i think that's gonna hurt
no no the black one yeah
well you chose it spank my okay i'm
gonna make you spank
the thing yourself you could spank it
with your [ __ ]
okay rude ew
i could spank it with my that's very
rude kala come here
oh my god wait do i do the crab hold on
wait camera though camera oh
oh my god wait did it really hurt a
little bit and then it felt good
he was right at the fan of your [ __ ]
too oh this one's a good whip
i i implore you to find a skinny part of
my body i had too much fun doing that
see but that's what i have envy about
having i always wanted a fat
i do have a little bit of like i do have
a venus mound like it
is like there's meat there like not me
oh god can we just get rid of our male
audience so we can just talk to girls
but yeah no i have a i have like uh guys
guys don't guys are down i just don't
like explain i don't want people to know
i mean you can see my tits but just like
in the swim team
and swim team i always like if i'm
standing sideways
you can see like the pad like here yeah
right here yeah but see that's what i
like
and that's what guys unfortunately for
you that's what that's what guys like
because like i have a friend who never
wears a plain colored tights
because you just see her giant [ __ ]
mouth i don't even know really what
you're talking about and i'm just going
to stay out of it like here
here esther touch if you touch mine i
have nothing like just do i have sure
put put your um put your hand
right on my pubis like my pubic
if we area and then compare it to annie
like no here right here it's bony right
and touch annie's
that there's a very slight difference oh
i
really don't know if i'm doing it right
but i'm not picking up on
it's cute i don't know i think this
episode is over
well baby slugs slugs r us
home slugs it's time to say goodbye yet
again
thank you for joining us today was a
mess
today was a mess for me to have just
gotten my [ __ ] slapped and you just say
a mess is so disrespectful you got your
[ __ ] stuff and i was like go home [ __ ]
yeah she was like on your way um
thank you for listening as always please
like this video subscribe to this
channel
comment for that algorithm and guys tell
your girlfriend tell your girlfriends if
you're a guy watching she's like i can't
believe i'm a guy watching this you have
to have like a girlfriend a mom
a sister a lover anything tell them we
want we love our ladies
in fact we guarantee your moms will love
this yes
that's a gift it is a weird mom show
which doesn't make any sense but my mom
and like my aunts like yeah
same they like it i don't know why well
people
not that i read comments but sometimes i
do but some one of the comments was
towards me was like i can't believe
annie would like talk that way in front
of esther's parents and like they watch
the show
yeah they don't care they watch it we're
proud of our products
we want you to just spread the joy to
your
female companions of your life so please
do that
what no [ __ ] whipping at home okay okay
don't try this at home unless you have
your own koloko
we'll see you guys next week bye guys
you